en vídeos anteriores mencionamos que si
dos variables aleatorias xy son
independientes entonces la varianza de
la suma o diferencia de dichas variables
será igual a la suma de la varianza de
cada una de las variables así que si
tenemos variables aleatorias
independientes
la variación va a aumentar cuando
sumamos o restamos varianzas vimos
intuitivamente porque esto tiene sentido
y en este vídeo veremos con más detalle
la importancia de que estas variables
sean realmente independientes para
asegurar esto consideremos dos variables
que son aleatorias pero no son
independientes entre sí digamos que la
variable aleatoria x es el número de
horas que una persona aleatoria durmió
ayer y digamos que la variable aleatoria
que es el número de horas que la misma
persona estuvo despierta ayer aquí
podemos notar que estas variables no son
independientes pues una variable
determina por completo a la otra
variable
si yo dormí 8 horas ayer quiere decir
que estuve despierta 16 horas y si ayer
dormí 16
horas entonces estuve despierta ocho
horas sabemos que aunque sean variables
aleatorias y x tenga una variación y ya
tenga otra variación cuando sumamos x +
ye como ambas variables tratan de la
misma persona
la suma siempre será igual a 24 horas
estas variables no son independientes si
nos dicen el valor de una de las
variables
entonces determinamos por completo el
valor de la otra variable la
probabilidad de obtener cierto valor
para una de las variables va a estar
determinada por el valor que tengamos en
la otra variable así que no son
independientes entre sí
digamos que la varianza de x es 4 y las
unidades de esta varianza son horas al
cuadrado la desviación estándar de x es
igual a 2 horas también digamos que la
desviación estándar de g es igual a dos
horas la varianza de g es el cuadrado de
su desviación estándar así que es igual
a 4 horas al cuadrado si quisiéramos
aplicar esta fórmula ciegamente sin
tomar en cuenta la independencia de las
variables diríamos que la varianza de x
+ debe ser igual a la suma de
varianzas individuales 44 es igual a 8
horas al cuadrado es esto correcto no no
tiene sentido porque sabemos que una
variable aleatoria que es igual a x +
jeff siempre será igual a 24 horas y
nunca tendrá variación alguna así pues
cuando tenemos estas dos variables que
están tan relacionadas no son para nada
independientes esto va a ser igual a
cero aquí no hay varianza alguna x más
siempre será igual a 24 al menos en la
tierra donde tenemos la duración de un
día aproximadamente igual a 24 horas
esto nos sirve para darnos una idea del
por qué es importante que las variables
sean independientes entre sí para este
enunciado si las variables no son
independientes este enunciado no tiene
sentido nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo